hey everyone it's sarah thredson are  sorry and calm and today we're going to  demonstrate how to get up and sit down  in a chair while using crutches to sit  in the chair the patient's going to back  up to the chair and fill the chair with  the non injured leg and when the patient  fills the chair with a non injured leg  they're gonna stop and move both  crutches over to the injured side for  support then the patient's going to grip  the hand grips and slightly bend the non  injured leg and feel behind them and  then set in the chair while keeping the  injured leg extended to get up from the  chair the patient is going to take the  crutches and put them on the injured  side for support he's going to keep the  injured leg extended and push up on the  non injured side and using the hand  grips of the crutches then he's going to  put the crutches in position thank you  so much for watching and don't forget to  subscribe to our channel for more videos